you know this has been going on for 17
centuries since saint nicholas went
around
and gave away his wealth to help others
and other people followed in his
custom of doing something for their kids
doing something for others
50-something years you said you've been
doing this 51 years this year oh
the 4 500 santas and mrs claus had
received diplomas from my school
4500 santas how is the the covet
season been for santa claus well it has
been
very very difficult for myself and of
course the many other gentlemen
tell me a little bit about the business
of being a santa claus you have to be
real
and we tell them that in the school you
know you are santa and number one job is
is the children what is the naughtiest
kid you've ever faced over these years
so all children i think deep down are
good they get into a little mystery once
in a while
what is the oldest person you met in
your life that still believed in santa
claus
i met a lovely lady who was
a 102 she wanted to go out on a date
is that your real beard right you have
on that's yours oh this is all real
that's what the little old ladies like
to pull on
it's always fun to meet people who
believe
[Music]
so listen with christmas being around
the corner i thought it was most
appropriate for us to bring
santa claus because we have to find out
if many of us have been naughty or not
if we're going to expect good things not
good things i don't know
i think it's just as important to you as
it is to me and my family because
my kids the other day gave me their
cards to to give to santa and i was
prepared for it
and i thought it was the right thing to
do to bring santa on and so today
my guest is santa tim also known as
santa hollywood who
is famous for being the official santa
for hollywood christmas parade
with that being said santa thank you so
much for being a guest on valuetainment
well thank you very much patrick and
hello to everybody out there
so it's it's good to have you i guess my
first question would be
how is the the covet season been for
santa claus
well it has been very very difficult for
myself and of course for those of your
listeners out there who
know what really goes on the many other
gentlemen with white beards who work
in all of the malls and shopping centers
and venues around the country
all of them are in fact around the world
all of them
are under various restraints and
restrictions this year
as to how much work they can do the type
of work they can do
and how we can interact with the
families
yeah i can only imagine that uh uh with
uh because
your uh your uh your model is seeing
kids your model is malls and if malls
are going through what they're going
through you're probably affected so
how has how has this affected you uh you
know from the standpoint of seeing kids
you know and and going to typical malls
have you guys had to adjust tremendously
well i think that uh as everyone has
adjusted
in their own lives in their homes and
everything
uh fortunately the internet and
skype and zoom have allowed more people
to communicate
and keep the face-to-face contacts going
and that is what a lot of santa's are
moving over to
there are a lot working in the malls in
the shopping center but
often there could be working behind
plexiglass or
uh socially distance where maybe the
family is on one side of the tree and
six feet away and the other side is
santa
and possibly they're all wearing masks
or maybe the sanders are wearing the
clear face shields i can't i can see
that you have to get creative at a
season like this so
if you don't mind us going back a little
bit with you is
how did you become santa because i know
you you you got an interesting story of
how you became santa i think it's a
problem we just go there first
well i always love santa claus i am the
oldest of 11 children and a
lovely irish catholic family so we
always had christmas in santa
and in 1969 i was serving in the army i
was in vietnam
and a friend of mine when we came back
into the base camp on december 23rd
to get our mail and have an early
christmas dinner
he put on some shaving cream as a beard
and sat in a folding chair and all of
the rest of us
soldiers sat down on his lap and had
pictures taken to
sent home to our moms and dads
after about 15 minutes that shaving
cream started melting and falling away
so i grabbed that can of barbasol and
put some shaving cream on and
sat in the chair and and with santa for
you know some of the soldiers in
our unit uh quite an experience
little did i know that a year later i
would be home going to college
working in a department store and they
came to me and said
um we know that you like broadcasting
and you were in the
high school theatrical group can you be
santa for a couple days
and thus started a career of wearing the
red suit
and how long has i been now since that
couple days well it's 51 years this year
holy moly
21 years ago not always with the real
beard
for many years it was a theatrical beard
but
as we say in the industry as i teach in
my santa school
the number one rule is we are there for
the children
very cool and very cool so what what
is i mean to become a santa and i've
heard that you've trained i don't know
through your school some nearly 4 000
other santa so tell tell me a little bit
about
the business of being a santa claus well
uh
about 20 22 years ago when i started
doing the
professional center work and my starting
to retire and everything
many of the sanders didn't know each
other there were been some going to
a school and there were a couple places
that did some training
one of them charles w howard school goes
back to 1938
um and it was once a year up in michigan
and um i had written a couple chapters
for
a book a friend who was writing and my
chapters were kind of like on
the work that we do the business that we
do and the requirements we have
and somebody said that was good and i
added more
and all of a sudden i had a full-fledged
book and someone said you should teach
this
so i started in 2003 my own santa school
and i traveled around the country going
to different cities to where the santas
lived
teaching them and uh as of uh
last year of santas and mrs claus
had received diplomas from my school
santas have received a diploma from your
school
yes how intense is the school well the
basic school is two days it's 16 hours
uh it covers everything starting at the
beginning from a little of the history
of santa claus from saint nicholas right
through to
uh present day uh you know a little bit
about uh the different characters the
media
some of the uh some of the things that
influence
the development of the santa from the uh
his travels you know he started in
turkey uh st nicholas was from turkey
and
as his stories traveled from
that area the mediterranean up into
europe and
then eventually uh to this new
continent over here to the u.s and
americas
all of the different countries
influenced the person
of santa claus with different customs
and different cultures
and much of it melded together in new
york
uh in the uh you know
part of the 19th century and we ended up
with santa claus in fact
the term santa claus first time in print
i believe
was in 1862 in the harpers weekly
1862 was the first time the term santa
claus was used
yeah well it had been used but in print
i know in 1862
i think that the dutch in new york had
sinterklas
and when the british took over uh new
amsterdam and renamed it new york
they required everybody to speak english
and sinterklaas
became santa claus so the name was
mentioned
but in print 1862. how much has changed
for you the season
uh uh you said you 50 something years
you said you've been doing this
how much has things changed over the
years of being santa claus during
christmas what have you noticed
um the big thing i've noticed is that
particularly in the last 20
25 years as the santas are
a little more stylish they do a little
more styling they more more
professional looking suits tailored and
of course
back in the 1970s you know the suit was
nice but
the belt was usually a vinyl or a cloth
with a little you know metal buckle and
they didn't really have real boots they
had
covers that covered their legs you know
so they wore street shoes with a cover
over them
as we moved into the uh the turn of the
century into
the you know into the 2000s and stuff
children are really smart
they can tell when something is not real
i mean
a child can watch a movie now and tell
you what cgi
so the thing is uh we have to have a
realistic suit so real belt and real
boots and uh and of course real beard
you know back in the 70s all the santas
and all the department stores
were theatrically bearded and today
rarely do you find a theatrically
bearded santa
if he is it's a high quality theatrical
beard it's one that you can
hardly tell you know but uh you know
today real bearded is
much much a necessity however i have to
clarify
you could put on a beard and a wig any
of your friends
ladies that you know could put on a
beard and wig and go into a little
daycare center with children five and
under and if you got on a red suit and
you've got a white beard
you're santa so the magic
still occurs even if you don't have a
real beard
i mean i i can appreciate you saying you
know anybody can be a santa you know i'm
sure middle eastern santas probably look
a little bit different than
american santa's than looked in any kind
of santas but
i've had to be a santa before and uh it
can be rewarding especially if you got
kids
and it can be costly if kids are
expecting nice gifts but what what has
been the most rewarding thing for you
for being santa for this many years
well you know i've been very lucky to do
a lot of events with celebrities and
i've done tv and film and things like
that
but i think one of the important things
is to be grounded
to be you know know the base
of what we do with santa and as i said
earlier the number one rule is the
children
and volunteer work with the children i
like i said at 4 500 santas and i
surveyed them and interviewed them and
uh
you know all of them do volunteer work
uh all over you know whether it's local
church work
school work in fact a lot of times they
actually got started
because someone came to him and said
would you volunteer to do something for
the school
or the church or something like that so
the volunteer work is important
and i truly enjoy doing work with
children's hospitals in fact this year
i'll be doing a lot with hasselfeld
children's hospital in new york city
but i've done things with the ronald
mcdonald house and
i'm also the national santa for the
marine corps toys for tots
so i get to do a lot of volunteer work
uh
we've done air lifts of toys into uh
areas that have been impacted by
hurricanes
natural disasters and so those are
the emotions you have with the families
and children
are very very special and when a uh
you know children give me a hug all the
time you know except this year of course
but when it's in it when it's one of
these special situations where
the family wasn't expecting anything
and you get that hug and you see their
face
you know i remember on dr phil
we had a whole bunch of children after
hurricane katrina
and he brought them all to hollywood and
well actually they were all in hollywood
or living in southern california because
different churches had
brought them in and were helping them
while
uh their families are trying to get
resettled
and all of these families uh were
brought to
the paramount studios and they had a big
event and afterwards
the children were brought into an area
where they had filled the entire street
with toys
every type of toy you could think of and
dr phil
the the gates were closed and doctor
bill said okay we open the gates
it says you get one of every toy you see
and they open the gates of the kids ran
in
and i'm sitting there doing my vocal
holes and having every time
but about 10 minutes in i'm standing
with some of the parents and the parents
are just
crying because they didn't expect
anything
they were wondering what they were going
to do for their children this year
and now their children had just
saw that santa opened his toy bag thank
you dr phil
uh and uh but again i'm sitting there
watering up when that happened so it's
it's those types of things i think that
give me a good base to work from
then i get to do the fancy stuff too you
know
would you say that's also the
characteristics of the
4 500 some santas that you've trained
that they have to have a heart for this
i think well again uh you have to be
real
and we tell them that in the school you
know you are santa and
your job is to to uh number one job is
is the children and you're there to
serve the children and to be santa to
them and to answer all their questions
and
take care of all their uh and you can't
always give them the exact
answer they want but you have to listen
to them and you have to give them
uh hopefully some optimistic outlook
how do you do that in this season
it is hard you know the children are
wondering how we're going to get to the
house the parents are actually wondering
how do they
help their child get the letter to santa
so that santa can
uh you know respond to them um
the marine corps toys for tots during
the spring months actually distributed
like three million
toys uh to children and families saw
around the country in areas that were
highly impacted and where the children
were
you know just you know it's terrible
you're stuck at home the parents are
stuck at home and
uh you know the parents don't have jobs
and it's just really rough
isn't it great to get the kids some
games or some books
keep their minds occupied and that's
something that
the marine corps did they have a little
side
thing that they do with the literacy uh
program
and so that's what they did they used
the books and the games for the kids
and this christmas uh we'll be doing
some airlifts i think we're going to do
one in puerto rico
and some other areas of the country
unfortunately uh
santa is a civilian and so i can't go on
some of these military flights
to uh to be with the children and
families but
the marines will get the toys to them
and help them have a little better
christmas
is the santa claus business model taking
a big
economic hit meaning our are our sound
our santa claus is the 4 500 that you've
trained are they part-time
this is what they do part-time as a
secondary income during december you're
mainly
inactive in the rest of the years 11
months you're pretty much doing other
full-time jobs
and i think 99.9 of the santas in the
words
almost all of them uh it is very
seasonal
in other words they they may have a real
beard it may
look like santa year-round but most of
them it's just this
30 or 40 days of the year that they get
to work
and this year when i i did a survey
just about a month ago and the results
of the survey
361 santas responded out of the
almost 3 000 i sent it to and they told
me that
about 20 of them said that they're not
going to be working
this year not going to be doing regular
visits they won't be in the mall
they won't be going to homes or
corporations or anything like that
uh 37 of the santas
in that survey said they will be doing
virtual visits
in other words they're going to be
either setting up their own
zoom type uh calls and doing a visit
or they're going or skype or something
like that or they'll be working for a
company like talk to santa
where they uh schedule times and then
they'll sit in front of a
computer like i am right now and for two
hours they'll
they'll take a call every 10 minutes
from a different family
and do little visits with the children
and uh
it's a one-on-one type thing and the
nice thing about talk to santa is that
they
uh the scent santa actually has a little
bit of information the elves have
put together the little biography or
little dossier on each trial
so santa can sit there and talk to the
children about their school
uh what they want for christmas he might
even have a little note of something
they did recently that was good
or maybe something recently that oh you
were naughty on
and uh so it makes a wonderful call and
so
so dr santa is doing that now and it's
quite nice
what is the naughtiest kid you've ever
faced over these years
naughtiest well all
children have a little bit of
naughtiness in them you know i always
children i ask will come up to me and
they'll say santa
i've been naughty or am i good i'll say
well
i know that every child has good days
and bad days
okay the object is to have more good
days than bad days so you
you know have a better better level on
the scale and everything so
uh so all children i think deep down are
good
you know they get into a little mischief
once in a while you know
i kid around sometimes you know again
depending on how old you are you
probably will get this joke but uh one
child can be creative two children get
very creative
three children together and one of them
turns into eddie haskell
or if not eddie haskell beetlejuice you
know
the kids challenge each other and get
into mission yes
very very common with that so now you
said you have children right
i do i have an eight-year-old a
seven-year-old and a three-year-old and
i can look i can go to that
seven-year-old and
and and say to the seven-year-old you're
not getting into your older uh
is it brother or sister brother two
older brothers
okay you're not getting into your older
brother's stuff are you
and that seven-year-old will sit there
sheepishly kind of like
yeah i do and the older one will say
yeah yeah he's always getting into my
stuff
you know and i can then look at the
eight-year-old and say
don't get mad your little brother is
just curious just
likes to look at your stuff i mean
you're curious too sometimes you sneak
in and look into daddy's stuff don't you
and the eight-year-old will probably get
big eyes and go
how did santa know classics and classics
so you know i looked at a data a couple
statistics i pulled out which i thought
it was pretty interesting
uh each christmas three billion
christmas cards are sent
in u.s alone okay another one is
according to data analyzed from facebook
post two weeks before christmas is one
of the two most popular times
for couples to break up however
christmas day is the least favorite day
for breakups
okay which i thought was pretty
interesting according to guinness book
of world records the tallest christmas
tree ever
cut was a 221-foot douglas fir
that was displayed in 1950 at the north
gate shopping center in seattle
washington
221 foot christmas tree that's a good
sized christmas tree
christmas trees have been sold in u.s
since 1850s
and you talked about the first time it
was called santa claus in a print was
coca-cola created the modern day muster
clause
and the department store santa's 120
year old tradition
and the age where most kids
flip and they no longer believe in santa
is eight years old what is the oldest
person you met in your life that still
believe
believed in santa claus i i met
a lovely lady who was uh
102 at a
rest home a convalescent home uh it
actually was very surprised she still
walked around and everything and uh she
gave me a big and she believed oh yes
uh-huh
she wanted to go on a date
[Laughter]
you know it's always fun
to meet people who believe you know
i've asked often you know why why
is this whole thing santa going on you
mentioned coca-cola
in the 1930s they had something
illustration of santa claus
and santa had been used in marketing and
advertising for many years
and so some people say well coca-cola
created the modern-day sale
well it evolved before that but the
reason santa exists and continues to
exist
is because of the parents and the
grandparents
and everything that they do for their
children and for others
you know this has been going on for 17
centuries
17 centuries since saint nicholas went
around
and and gave away his wealth to help
others and other people
followed in his habit his uh
custom of doing something for their kids
doing something for others
and it's because we seem to get an
enjoyment
doing something for others and we do it
for our children and we love doing it
and that feeling that we get is so good
we want to do it again so we repeat it
and
look what's happened yeah i bet
the feeling of giving is a priceless
feeling in christmas there's nothing
like it when everybody comes together
you're almost forced to do it you know
we like to do it period but christmas is
like
a mandatory time so for someone like you
are are you married have you been
married do you have kids
yes i've been married uh almost 35 years
we have a
lovely daughter we have a one and a half
year old grandbaby
and uh they've lived near us here and uh
so i i get that enjoyment in fact we
just
the one child i got to hold for a
christmas photo
is my granddaughter you know and that's
you know the rest of the kids it's
it's all social distance you know
sometimes we have a sign
here's santa here's the family there's
six feet in between
and the sign says i'm six feet from
santa
this is as close as i'll get to the nice
list
that's fine you gotta find a way to get
creative so how is it being married to
santa or having a
data center or even a grandpa santa
well i don't think my granddaughter
knows yet what's going on she's only
a year and a half uh my daughter has
enjoyed it
i've actually as part of my santa school
i've actually had
a dozen uh cruises we've gone on
princess cruises a dozen times with
anywhere from
20 to 40 couples all santas and mrs
claus
and my daughter's gone with it so she's
experienced hanging around with the
santas and things like that
and uh so it it it's been very very
enjoyable
did you guys meet when you were dressed
as santa or no
oh well when you have a little beard
like this and uh
all the white hair to go with it why uh
of course the uh the thing is is that uh
you're santa year-round you know 24 7
365.
and uh so sometimes you don't always
need the red suit
you know you can uh people will see this
cruddy mustache and they see this beard
i mean
[Laughter]
is that your real beard right you have
on that's yours that's not
uh no additions here no this is all real
you know that's what the little old
ladies like to pull on
yes you know you mentioned something
about the eight-year-old little video
eight-year-old yes and of course
normally what happens is that one of the
older kids tells the
the eight-year-old the story
and uh i often get parents asking me
what do i do when my child comes home
and says
my friends tell me there's no santa you
know and
i i encourage all families to teach
their children about giving
secret giving uh adopting another child
or family and giving something away
teach them about the joy of giving so
they feel that that warm fuzzy feeling
and when the day does come then you can
tell the child says well you know saint
nicholas was a real person
he taught us all about giving so we
started doing things for our children
you're going to have to do it for your
children and you now have to become one
of the secret givers that helps others
and you so you teach your children this
they will follow along with it
and they'll and usually the older kids
if they believe in that
they'll help take care of the little
kids
so your seven and eight year old take
care of the three girls
that's very powerful the secret giving
part you know to teach uh
the the oldest oldest you know older
brother older sister who
maybe learns about santa claus you take
the approach of teaching them secret
giving
so before we wrap up i'm assuming you've
watched
uh maybe maybe it's a bad assumption to
make have you watched most of the santa
movies
watch them yourself and if yes what's
your favorite i do
do try to catch some of the movies now
there's an important aspect of this
um all santas need to understand and
know
that the children have seen all of these
movies they've read all of the books
and we have to know all of those things
because children will come to santa and
say
can i see your tattoos and there was a
movie a few years ago where santa had
tattoos that said naughty and knights
and
so in santa school we teach the santas
if a child
asks you that you know you could say
well they're magical tattoos they only
appear when i need them
you know and because you you know you
don't want to go out and have to have
your arm
inked uh although i noticed some guys on
your staff there are already
uh but again uh we have to know what's
going on in the movies so that we can
answer the children's questions
what's your favorite movie what's your
favorite movie miracle on 34th street
okay old school
yeah my dad's as well i mean i've seen
the new uh
christmas chronicles with kurt russell
which are quite good and have some neat
things in it
uh i wish i could sing as well as he
does
have you seen elf with will ferrell i've
seen elf with will ferrell in a funny
funny movie and uh
with the uh the four food groups
all being sugars he was pretty excited
when he saw you i mean when he saw you
in the mall he was very excited about it
don't know
yeah in fact i think there's some little
video clips that you can get
to you know uh the way he uh got so
excited
but again uh those are parts of the joy
you know that make it wonderful uh you
know being able to take your
in fact that was a broadway musical for
a while so your families would take the
children and see that like they take
go see the rockettes even the movie
christmas story
the one with the little boy who visited
santa and
santa said no you shoot your eye out uh
even that was made into a broadway
musical so
there's lots of entertainment out there
lots of fun
for the children and the families as
santa i kind of have to
know what's going on go along with it
well
you know i want to thank you for coming
on and being a guest i know you got your
what too
so did you say you have two 190 pound
dogs
in your place or you got reindeers as
well
well we have reindeer of course there's
thousands of reindeer that help us out
here
but uh my personal dogs i have uh noel
uh she is 180 pound uh
black newfoundland and her sister is
not a bear and because she
is not a bear looks like a bear but is
not a bear
just a big 180 pound dog big 180 pound
dog my gosh and they're waiting for
santa to go feed them right now because
it's dinner time
yes it is huh well santa tim thank you
so much for making the time for being a
guest on valuetainment
how can people find you by the way well
i want you to find me i'm on the web at
nationalsanta.com
thank you i appreciate that and of
course i want all your uh
viewers and anybody listening you know
here's my logo back here for toys for
tots
you know if uh you have an opportunity
visit the website for toys for
thompson.org
this year because a lot of people can't
drop anything in a barrel
they can go online and uh order a
virtual toy for a child
they you know make a donation and that
way we can still reach
probably about eight million children
this year and uh
we need to do that it's very very
important we will definitely
do that as well any final thoughts of
optimism for 2021
well uh enjoy the holiday season do what
you can to have
a good time with your family even though
you're stuck at home
uh do know that there are ways that if
you can't get to a ball or a shopping
center
you can go to sites like talk to santa
and
or go online and there are different
ways for the children to
experience a visit with santa awesome
thank you so much merry christmas bless
you patrick and bless
all your listeners merry christmas merry
christmas bye bye
bye so it's pretty crazy even the
pandemic affected the santa claus
business which last year you heard him
say 30 to 40 days
but learn a little bit more about how
his uh world is at santa if you know
christmas time it's a very heartwarming
mormon time for kids family go to them
all take pictures
it's exciting for kids to go through and
they want to have that so another
additional thing to be thinking about by
the way if you enjoyed this interview
here
with santa tim uh adam sosnick did a
video
on black friday christmas spending the
whole nine of what it's like during
holidays
on vitamin economics if you have not
watched it click over here to watch it
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye
[Music]